and then we were like all right fine
deal like that's you know this business
was so freaking hard like let's try this
and uh in the end I don't think it ever
ended up working but you got the
customers and that's the point of the
episode yeah exactly the subsequent
failure is irrelevant okay
[Music]
yeah all right we're live Sean we're
going to do a Q&A session today we got a
bunch of questions I have a feeling
we're going to spend most of the time on
one question but the question is how did
you get your first 100 customers in your
businesses and what are the best ways
that you've heard of so I I'll ask you
Sean but uh I've personally have grown I
think five things to a million to 10
million in Revenue I've grown one thing
to well north of 10 million in Revenue
multi-million dollars per month I've
grown a bunch of stuff to thousands of
users I've grown a bunch of stuff to
hundreds of thousands and I've grown one
thing to millions and we'll go through
examples and uh you've done the same you
how many did did bibo have or blab blab
had like four million users um yeah
basically we've done this a bunch of
different times and a bunch of different
ways and so when we get this question
you know how did you get your first 100
customers I actually really like this
question this is a very different
question than like you know what's your
advice it's like forget the advice let
me tell you literally what I did when it
comes to how we grew our businesses at
the very very start because if you're at
the start it doesn't matter what
somebody did to go to get to 10 million
in Revenue what matters is what the they
got the $10 in Revenue how did they get
the ball going how did they get the
initial momentum because if you don't do
that by definition you don't really get
to you know you don't get to step two
unless you've done step one and so this
is the uh the step one episode and I
thought it'd be fun if we take the our
own like just all the different projects
that we've done and just try to label
the method that we use to go and get
those first 100 customers that are that
got the ball rolling do you want to go
back and forth yeah let's trade off all
right so the first thing that I grew I'm
actually not going to talk about it a
lot because I didn't realize it but I
was breaking the law but it was I had an
e-commerce store and I originally got my
first 100 customers by posting in uh
forums but I'm not going to mention that
statute of by the way is that a real
thing the statute of limitations like is
it is there a real thing uh maybe we
need producer AR to let us know by the
way show her in her sweater fantastic
sweater okay it's not a thing all right
so so correct do not tell people what
you were doing I thought after 10 years
everything's forgiven no I'm not going
to mention that but all right the first
first uh my first business was called
bunk it was like my first like actual
startup out of college it was called
bunk it was a roommate matching app it
was Tinder for roommates which I always
say was stupid we should have done
Tinder for Tinder because this was right
when Tinder came out it was like swiping
like clicking Les yes or no um but
before it became an app we actually just
had a website that was built on Weebly
we probably did 50,000 in sales in a
handful of months something like that
and what we used to do is in San
Francisco it's mostly transient people
so people like me and sea who moved
there without knowing too many people
and you want to rent a one-bedroom
apartment but you can't afford a
one-bedroom apartment and so instead
there's a four-bedroom apartment where
there's one room left and you apply to
move in there what a lot of people don't
know is back then and I don't know if
it's this way now but back then
literally a 100 people would apply for
that one bedroom so the way that we got
users is we went and found people who
had like landlords who had four bedroom
apartments and three bedroom apartments
and we said hey we're going to host an
event it's not going to be a party it
was party it's going to be an event at
your three and four bedroom apartment
and we're going to have a bunch of
perspective tenants there and they're
going to team up and get their own place
and so let's say that it was a
four-bedroom place for 4,000 we would
create individual ads for a one-bedroom
at $11,000 and we and back then on
Craigslist you could use HTML and create
these beautiful like images of what the
apartments looked like and it said this
is bunk SF we help people match people
this is a one-bedroom and a four-bedroom
but we're going to help you team up and
we we would get like like 10,000 users
uh a week coming to our bunk sf.com
website and that's how I got our first
bit of users was through
Craigslist and the point being the
takeaway by the way is we already knew
the Seekers were there and so it was
just a piggyback where people already
were I can find this client info have
you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hopspot grow
better so the the smart part there is
using Craigslist cuz Craigslist already
had a lot of search volume basically you
instead of SEO you use basically CEO so
like go go to Craigslist and get uh use
that traffic but then hosting the event
what did you do in these events by the
way was there anything special you did
or like how did you get people to did
you have to make it marketable or did
you just make it normal because I know
for the hustle you had these great
little events that you use called pizza
and for
where you would invite a speaker to an
event but the you would tape two 40 o
beers to their hands and the rule this
is a genius by the way this was so good
I remember when you did this I was like
that guy Sam is cool I want to be
friends with him literally had that
thought and I didn't even drink by the
way at this point I didn't even drink
but the name of the game was pizza in
40s because we didn't have a lot of
money so we'll Supply Costco pizza and
we'll have beer and the speaker has to
have a 40 oce beer and the the interview
is done when the 40 o beer is done right
right it's like a TED talk but instead
of 18 minutes it was however long it
takes him to finish the beer if he wants
to get off the stage chug baby chug and
and you'd get a little bit more Loosey
Goosey with the questions towards the
tail that was genius so that one was
marketable was your did you have to do
that for the apartment thing or was it
as simple as saying hey come check out
this so we would get like hundreds of
applicants for a one uh for like a four
bedroom and we just emailed them and and
we are very transparent in the ad it
said this is not a one-bedroom it's a
one-bedroom and a four bedroom but what
we're doing is we're going to host a
party with 50 people here's the types of
people who are coming show up at this
time and then they would team up and get
a place and once they got a place the
landlord would tell us it came from us
and we would take money from both the
user and the landlord and um uh yeah we
were just really transparent about it
and I would literally like ride my bike
at the time to the house and be like
knock knock I'm give me your $100 please
uh or $300 or however much it was and
that's how we made money but no it was
that was very easy but now you can't do
this uh Craigslist has changed how they
operate but this by the way is exactly
how Airbnb got popular um all right
what's yours all right I'm GNA give you
my first business as well so this is uh
I'm 21 years old we are starting a sushi
restaurant chain and I'm living in
Denver and the way our thing worked it
was like a cloud kitchen so it was um
because we didn't want to sign a 10-year
lease and build out a physical location
and have to go raise
$500,000 we had a mentor who was like
what what if you did a delivery only a
delivery only method and you um rented a
commissary kitchen by the hour I
remember we were paying $9 an hour
instead of having to so like the
contrast was we were about to sign a
10year lease with a personal guarantee
and drop about 300 $500,000 to build it
out or for $19 an hour we could start
Monday and 15 years you're 15 years in
the future I mean you you nailed it yeah
we too early but still it so how do we
get customers back then door Dash Uber
Eats didn't exist so where are we going
to get customers for our delivery only
restaurant I didn't know any better
knowing what I know now I probably would
have just run ads local ads maybe
Facebook ads Google ads something like
that for people looking for sushi but I
didn't know that at the time and
ignorance is a bit of a superpower so
the ignorance led us to our planning
meeting was like 12 minutes long it's
like we need customers so like hey we
got the kitchen now like we need
customers hey um I don't know walk
around ask people so what I did was I
went downtown and I did a version of
door Tod door but instead of door too I
did floor to floor so I went into a
skyscraper because I wanted density so I
was like oh let me just go to this big
office building there's thousands of
people working in this one building so I
don't have to walk around all day I can
just go in the elevator click one get
out and talk to whoever I see click two
get out talk to whoever I see I'll go up
you know 30 40 flights in this building
and what I realized when I was doing
this was um it's kind of amazing I
actually recommend this to pretty much
anyone which is when you have a thing
you you have all these ideas about why
it's so great but you haven't actually
like pitched it to somebody in a concise
way where you have I don't know 30
seconds to a minute to like get your
foot in the door and then maybe another
minute to explain what your thing is and
then you got to make a call to action
and try to get them to buy and my pitch
really sucked but because I was floor to
floor it was like high 20 by 4 which was
solid I knew and so what I realized was
okay you go in you can't just bother
people in an office you have to find the
front desk lady her job is to greet a
visitor so I said okay that's the
accessible person she also had a lot of
clout and so I learned about basically a
local influencer so when people think
about influencers they think it's got to
be a celebrity but actually in any in
any pocket of people there is somebody
who is more influential than the rest
any tribe of people and in an office
that's always the person at the front
desk it's the office manager the
secretary whatever you want to call it
and so I would go to this kind of office
manager and I would say um I would say
hey do you guys ever do so instead of
saying hey would you like to eat some
sushi it's like no I don't just eat
sushi from strangers I realized pretty
quickly that was my first pitch by floor
two I was like all right I'm not saying
that again so floor three and four I
realized okay I should actually ask them
like do they ever um do you guys ever do
office catering for lunches or whatever
for the for the for the group and they
would say yes so I asked a question that
had a very simple answer a yes or no
answer if it was no then I knew don't
waste my time on this Prospect they're
not going to order but if it was yes yes
now I had one person who might order 50
lunches um in one order right like they
would order bulk and so I would ask them
hey do you ever order uh you know do you
guys ever do catering for office lunches
maybe a birthday or a big meeting or or
just every Wednesday and they were like
yeah we do it every Wednesday I'd be
like awesome I said when you order um
where do you typically order from oh we
always do the sandwich place blah blah
blah I said awesome um if you ever
wanted to try something new we actually
just opened up a restaurant I was love
to do a deal with you guys where we
actually do it for free one time right
so I created an offer I was like I'd
love to bring you a sample tray just for
you and you can invite a couple people
in the office to try it out if you guys
like it we'll leave a menu with you guys
if you don't like it no problem we'll
come back clean it up and I created an
offer I created an opening question and
I ended up getting my pitch right and
this one thing we were profitable month
one I remember we made like 13 Grand in
the first month and like at the time
everybody said restaurants you don't
make any money and we were like we're
doing it we're making money this is
fantastic and so this Florida FL to
floor sales and understanding who is the
gatekeeper who is the person I need to
get on board and what is the the sort of
uh risk-free offer that I can offer them
was the way we got our first first
customers how much revenue were you
doing in year six or not year six month
year six zero dude we quit in month
three because what we realized was we
were like all right we were making I
don't know tens of thousands a month so
I think we were doing like maybe 30,000
the first month and a little bit more
the second month and then by then it was
like dude we were so worn out of the
just the process of running a restaurant
and we we kind of had a realization like
great we can keep scaling this but that
means we're going to have to keep doing
this and it was you know we were waking
up at 4 in the morning going to the fish
market staying there till 11: at night
because we would do private caterings at
night and doing dishes and the then
night we didn't know anything it was so
stupid I didn't realize you should hire
people we just did everything like you
were like looking at your partners one
day after work and you're like bail and
they're like baale like we're out we had
a realization we we realized we were in
the wrong business we realized actually
the the the genius of this was the
delivery part people actually liked food
delivery but they only ate sushi every
couple weeks Max and so we were like oh
you know what we should do we've been
telling everyone for a year we're going
to create the next you know this
Chipotle of sushi actually what we
should do is just deliver whatever the
hell they actually want they want
sandwiches dude they want burritos so we
should just deliver that that's the
business not the sushi part and then we
were like all right I think that's true
do we want to do that I was like and you
know we had the smart thing which was
hey guys maybe the first business idea
we ever had in our lives might not be
the best one and uh we're still young
and we haven't committed anything to
anybody what if we just switched to a
better to a different business alog
together and I'm so glad we had that
conversation because most of the time if
something's working you're making a
little bit of money and you've been
telling everyone for a year you just
feel like you need to stay consistent
with it and that would have been a
terrible decision for us um that's
hilarious um all right I'll tell you uh
another one so I'll skip the book club
one but I'll mention it briefly I had a
book club the anti mba.com and that's
how I met sea I met Ryan Hoover this way
uh some of my best friends dude I just
put another ad on Craigslist and I said
I'm organizing a business book club and
it was just from Craigslist and I ended
up getting 10,000 people signing up to
my email list by the way again sorry can
we name these methods I will call the
first one you did either like uh
piggybacking because you piggybacked off
Craigs or like a host an event maybe
that was the method you did for mine it
was literally door too and like don't
underestimate the fact that you can just
by Brute Force hand toand combat go get
a 100 customers that way it'll only take
you a few days to do that um and this
third one you're talking about the book
club we call it like the magnet there's
something different to it because it
wasn't just an event because what you
did was you found a bunch of like-minded
people because there was a filter the
only people who want to do a book club
for on for like biographies and business
books are going to be the type of
business nerds that you wanted to be
around and create a product for and so
like the selective filter where for 95%
of the people they're GNA be like hell
no but 5% there're it's a hell yes
because it's like so nich to their
obsessions and I think that there's
something smart there that's different
than just hosting a general event it's a
magn the learnings by the way for a book
club no one reads the book except me I
was the only one who read the book I was
just like teaching the book um all right
I'll do the second one though all right
so bunk was acquired for a very small
sum and we ended up turning it into an
app called roommates what'll call this
methodology made to stick I guess
because I learned this I uh one of the
books that we read at my book club was
called made to stick it was by Dan and
Chip Heath I think they're experts on
like verality and there was something in
the book where it talked about I forget
exactly the phrase but it but my
takeaway was that phrase that I always
say niches make riches and the idea
being if you ever see one of these
BuzzFeed articles and it'll be like 50
ways you 50 reasons why or uh 50 50
things only only long Islanders will
laugh at right or 50 things you know
you're an Italian Aman or 50 ways you
know you're from St Louis and the thing
about those is they don't get a huge
amount of traffic but the people in Long
Island or St Louis or who are Italian
they will always click it they and so
the click D rate is through the roof and
so we didn't have a budget when we
launched the app roommates and so what
we did was I stole that that that
learning and I created we launched in La
Chicago Boston New York San Francisco
five or six cities and so what we did
was we made an infographic where we
called it the typical roommates of San
Francisco the typical roommates of LA
and I had never even been to LA or New
York or Boston I'd never even been there
and what we did was each image of the
infographic it was 18 people I think or
15 people and it said here's the people
from the marina which is a neighborhood
in in San Francisco here's a typical
roommate from the mission which is the
Hipster area of San Francisco and in
each thing we said where do they shop
and we named eight or four different
places that they would shop where do
they eat what what's a funny quote they
would say and I would read Yelp and I
would find out in in let's say New York
like what is a the most reviewed
restaurant on Yelp in that area and are
people making jokes and saying that
overhyped or whatever and which stores
are the most popular and then what we
did we made those infographics and we we
shared them out on Facebook and Twitter
and I think Instagram I don't even
remember where and we tagged those
restaurants and those stores and most
people are like oh this is so funny they
totally know us which we just stole it
from Yelp all the jokes and they ended
up sharing it and we got something like
a 100,000 users just from that
infographic just from those five
infographics and if you Google you guys
can Google um typical roommates of LA
and you'll see H dep post or all the
local newspapers of those regions shared
it and that's how we got all of our
initial customers from uh from those
four or I remember seeing that I
remember seeing the San Francisco one it
was really funny it would be like like
you're making it sound almost like it
was like uh like utilitarian but it was
actually humorous I thought like it
wasn't funny the shop it would be like
the marina it's like and then it'd be
like whatever I don't remember exactly
how you phrase it but it would be like
um uh here you're gon to find Kelsey is
blah blah blah and you would kind of
like make fun of them but also
backhanded compliment them and then you
would say like you know the upside you
you know you'll always have um you know
Lululemon around the house the downside
blah blah blah and you would like kind
of poke fun at them and because of that
everybody shared it because for their
own neighborhood they'd be like that's
so true that's so true that's so us oh
my God this is you and then for others
that they didn't like the other
neighborhoods same thing it was like
kind of like our team versus their team
and so a lot of people shared this thing
I was living in San Francisco at the
time I remember seeing that right when I
actually moved there and I was like this
is actually quite it was useful because
it's like it's not info you really found
anywhere else either like uh it was like
supposed to be like the real the real
take so here's an example this is
Wrigleyville in Chicago I've never even
been there but it's an image of a broy
looking guy who I guess went to Indiana
University and he's wearing a cub shirt
it said average one-bedroom rent average
two-bedroom rent um here's how much you
would save if you had a roommate and it
says $310 per month or 20 Merkel
fishbowls which I guess is like a
restaurant in that area or it would say
um avoids pilson and Andersonville so it
creates like the tribe thing those are
other neighborhoods occupation a PE
teacher or a weekend bartender at Deuces
uh you'll probably find them at R
Wrigley Field rooftops crushing old
Styles or doing 17 shots a fireball
secret spot the back bar at of the
stretch trying to to get the waitress to
play find the water or calling everyone
boss [__] they say hey bro want a shot
ski so like things like that where we'
make fun of people but you'll notice we
name as many Brands as possible the name
of the game was throwing as many Brands
as possible and those ref and those are
the people who share and that is how we
got I forget exactly how many users we
had but I remember I got paid on how
many swipes people did and they were
Swip in millions and millions and
millions of times right so that's how we
got uh that's how we got traffic and
users to the app roommates all right I'm
going to tell you uh I'm going in order
here so my next business was a biotech
business in Australia that um go to
Australia now biotech is a very like
like we're talking about like Scrappy
startup stories like how do you get
somebody to download an app how do you
get somebody to like order food biotech
is like science people in it just go to
an alley and you're like hey man here's
a needle do you uh you want to try well
it wasn't like human body biotech it was
basically energy clean energy so the
idea was our our technology was there's
coal that's underground and people think
coal is real dirty because if you mine
it you bring it up to the surface and
you burn it yes it is very like bad for
the environment however our technology
was this thing where you don't have to
mine it so you don't have to bring it
out of the ground and you don't have to
burn it instead what you do is you pump
little microbes into the ground little
naturally occurring microbes and their
natural feeding is basically they eat
the coal they they basically decompose
the coal is like they eat coal and they
fart out natural gas so their natural
metabolism of it will release natural
gas which then bubbles back up to the to
your pipe in the surface and uh boom you
have a flare of natur was this like a
company like a big company yeah it was a
company it was a startup company so
basically this the backstory was this
guy in the United States the scientist
in United States had been had gotten $40
million of government funding to develop
microbes that would uh decompose
ammunition because the government had uh
there's Wars all around the world and
part of of the like the environmental
cleanup they had to do as part of the
wars was they needed something that
would decompose a lot of the ammunition
and the the the waste product of the
wars and so what happened was somebody
realized you know the guy who the CEO of
our company realized hey ammunition
actually has a very similar composition
to Coal I wonder if these bugs could
decompose coal and so but it was
speculative and we didn't know if it
would work it worked in the lab will it
work in the field now what are you going
to do here to get your first customers
right to get a customer you need some
that has owns like land that has coal
you have to have permits they have to
let you like go do [__] on their land
how is this going to happen it's like so
much friction so what we did was what
I'll call the method of the no risk
offer so what we did was we would go to
we we said who needs this the most and
we said Well it can't be somebody that
actually values their coal because we're
going to go and we don't have the money
to go buy this coal like we can't buy
the land from them like if you own land
with a bunch of you know coal that's
basically like fuel like that's very
valuable property so we said we need to
go to people that have stranded coal
meaning they have coal that mining it
would be uneconomic it'd be too deep
it'd be too garly the way the the ground
structure is so there is coal but like
it's not good for Mining and so we got
really tight on basically finding some
for somebody for whom this was excess
capacity and I think they know like
Airbnb that's what they did right they
sold excess rooms excess space in your
house so we had took that same method we
said how do we make a no risk offer so
we went to them and we said look you're
sitting on a bunch of coal what's that
like who's an example like the landowner
we would find we would do a geographic
we looked at the geographic survey we
would find where the stranded coal was
meaning Cole that's not economic to be
mined then we would go figure out from
the property like Records who owns that
we would go knock on their door we say
did you know you're sitting on a bunch
of coal and they'd be like yeah but like
you can't really mine it we did a
feasibility study it didn't work and we
would say great what if I told you there
was a way that you could make this many
dollars per square foot without mining
the coal and yeah I'm interested okay
tell me more and we said well look we
have this technology but you know
obviously we need to prove it it'll only
take us this much space and here's the
deal we will do this all at our cost to
do this whole method cost you nothing
and but if it works we want to share of
The Upside and they were like okay so
you might make my land way more valuable
and I only pay you if you do it and if I
don't if it doesn't work I'm out I'm out
nothing deal and and I'll throw in a
tray of sushi exactly and so we were
able to do this now this is something
that this is also how Alex heroi did his
gym launch thing if he listen to his
story what he would do is he'd go to the
gym owners he'd say uh you know I have a
marketing program they're like I don't
want to buy it we tried a bunch of
marketing things I don't have I don't
have enough money money anyways to go do
this I'm not going to buy your marketing
program for $10,000 so he reworked his
offer and he was like how about this if
I don't incre I will I will increase
your sales by $100,000 using my
marketing method and all I say is that
anything we any of the incremental
Revenue we bring in we get to keep
whatever 15% it's like okay so you keep
15% but like you don't get anything if
you don't raise my my Revenue it's like
yeah we if we don't raise your Revenue
by X we get nothing yeah no brainer
Heros did a no Nob brainer offer Main
Street did the same thing grew really
fast in the tech startup Community by
saying hey there's R&D tax credits
available we will do it for you we keep
20% or 25% of all this all the extra tax
credits you get you're not going to do
this anyway ways so it's just free money
for you um and so a lot of people use
this this no-risk offer method and I
think that's a very very fast way to
bypass one of the hardest parts is if
you're a new company which is you have
no relationships nobody trusts you
nobody you have no track record so you
need to offer them something that has
like zero downside and only upside how
many customers did you get doing that
well ironically what ended up happening
was we had like five intered customers
and then one of them was like hey hey
hey if you're going to do this I want I
want to own this technology like if it s
like basically don't go to my
competitors with this offer like they're
going to then they're going to have you
know this benefit I want this and so
then they they came back later and they
renegotiated the deal and they said how
about this we'll give you $5 million and
the land and we'll do the permitting for
you um but and then we're like okay
what's the catch and they're like the
catch is if this works we want to be
able to buy 50% of the technology for 50
million and then we were like all right
fine deal like that's you know this
business was so freaking hard let's try
this and uh in the end I don't think it
ever ended up working or I'm not sure
what actually happened cuz I left after
that deal was signed I was like turn out
microbiomes microbiomes don't even like
charcoal so turns out in the lab but
it's like it I think it turned out to be
kind of expensive or what actually
happened is this field trial was going
to take five years to do I wasn't going
to sit around and wait till the to the
conclusion of this and so I think what
happened was like the guy who said yes
got fired or took another job the next
guy who came in was like ah I don't know
I don't want to fund this and I have no
idea what happened it kind of died on
the vine but you got the customers and
that's the point of the episode yeah we
exactly the subsequent failure is
irrelevant okay yeah that doesn't matter
um all right my next one so uh I started
a conference series called hustle con I
ended up hosting this event maybe four
or five times the first time I hosted it
I decided to host it in May and I think
it went uh the event happened in July
uh July 1 or July 15 but I had roughly
six weeks between deciding to do it and
it happening and I think I made 60 Grand
in revenue and I think 50,000 in profit
the next year I think it was something
like 180 Grand in revenue and my costs
were only 20 grand so whatever that is
that's what I made and then I did it
again and I think I made like a quarter
of a million in revenue and like 200,000
in profit um and then we hosted a bunch
more events P you did like 600k right
right yeah it made each event was doing
like a couple times we got close to a
million and I made a ton of mistakes the
biggest mistake I made is I made it like
a Ted event not like a trade show had I
made it like a trade show I probably
could have made tens of millions per
event but I just didn't know what I was
doing and I also charged like $300 to
attend this event so I screwed up the
business but I did get a lot of uh hype
right away and the way that I got hype
was I actually found one of my old posts
um I would uh this one is on
priceonomics so this guy Rohan Rohan he
had a Blog called priceonomics and at
the time they were like the best
bloggers out there he was such a good
blogger and he would go viral all the
time so he was going to give a talk on
content marketing and what I would do is
I think I had eight speakers I wrote a
blog post every Tuesday and Thursday on
each speaker and I would go to Hacker
News and I would go to Reddit and I
would figure out which subreddits would
this article fit best in and then later
on and my second thing I'm going to talk
about after uh after youo is I ended up
eventually writing blog posts
specifically that would go get popular
in Reddit or on Reddit in different like
subreddits but at this point I hadn't
figured that out and so right away I
think on the first day of business I
think I got a thousand people to come uh
to the website and then after that it
would go to like 1,000 to 5,000 on any
given day and you would go to the
website and it would say a funny popup
that I would get your attention and I
would say give me your email and the
hustle.com you couldn't even purchase a
ticket unless you gave me your email you
couldn't even see all the details and so
I would get people's email and I would
subsequently like the way I had it set
up was I would write blog post number
one put it on Reddit blog post number
two put it on Reddit the traffic comes I
collect their email when I get their
email they go into a cycle where they
get sent blog post number one then I get
blog post number two and then I would
keep writing blog post number three
number four number five and I would keep
emailing it to the Past people so it was
like a cycle and those people would
share just a little bit and that's how I
eventually got two three four five
thousand people coming to the website
and I did another thing where I made the
speaker look like a hero so it was like
a glowing article about them and they
would share it within their company and
the each employee would share it to be
proud and that's how I got two three
four five thousand people and I think I
think the email list I if you Google um
hustle con Nev blog so my friend Neville
madora Nev NE
vblog he wrote a blog post about how I
made 60 Grand in like six weeks and I
list all the blog posted emails that I
sent and that's originally uh how we got
our first I think 10,000 email
subscribers um is just doing that
blogging and and when I say we I mean me
in my kitchen uh just like doing this in
my crappy San Francisco apartment that's
yeah that's great I remember reading
those blog posts they're really good I
highly suggest you go read those uh
they're detailed and specific and you
literally have screenshots of what you
wrote in certain emails and I think
that's really cool to go see I like when
people share those specifics um but do
you hear
that do you hear that that's the no dude
that's the that's the thrill of the
shill
Oh I thought we had a pause I thought we
had a pause I was like wait what uh all
right you've got 90 seconds to to to
Thrill me all right for those who don't
remember the thrill of the shill is
where we sh a thing but the way we do it
is with value we do it with we by by
entertaining with a little bit of story
so I was going to talk to you about
Shephard but the way I did it was I
asked Marshall I go yo when you launch
this thing because this is now a
business that is coming up on like I I
guess I really shouldn't say but
millions of dollars of profit a year so
a very very very healthy business how
old are they four years uh yeah like
less than four years old so uh in less
than four years getting to you know
basically eight figures in profit profit
not Revenue profit so anyways I was like
hey dude I'm doing this episode about
how you got your first 100 customers
what did you do for for Shephard he goes
um he goes well I did a couple of things
but he's like what I did was I he's
linked me to the Tweet so he did three
like three or four steps in a row so
tweet one I'll show this on the screen
he just goes I'm launching a new
business tomorrow and then he did the sh
sign emoji and then he said hint it's an
agency and he had a small Twitter
following about 10,000 followers at the
time
um not like a huge mega influencer but
enough and that that post itself has 350
likes so that post itself probably got a
bunch of people being curious going
inbound and then what he did next he's
like I'm gonna explain it on my
newsletter so he goes to the newsletter
and he writes this post and he goes
today I'm launching this new business
but let me tell you a story and he goes
a few years ago my business is
struggling here's why so he does what I
call the personal story tactic which is
instead of pitching the solution that
you've made you pitch the problem that
you had and you tell a personal story
where you reveal some information you do
some vulnerability and hopefully other
people resonate with the problem that
you had so he goes uh my business was
was doing good and he's like but I uh or
he's like I had this business it was
kind of struggling I was working all the
time but we never really had any profits
I realized I I always thought I could
solve the problem with growth and then
finally one day I was like maybe I
should try to lower my costs I didn't
really know what to do so I looked for
where could I lower my cost he goes I
heard about a guy who had hired somebody
in the Philippines for less than $1,000
a month meanwhile I was paying somebody
000 for the same service so I did it I
did another one here's a picture of me
in the Philippines you know we went out
and met them because I was so amazed at
how this worked he goes and so then that
became my secret weapon I was hiring
overseas and so now all of a sudden I
went from profit margin of zero to
profit margin of whatever 15% and that
made the difference between the business
sucking to the business being good so I
started doing this for a few friends
just for fun finally decided I'm going
to make a business called support
cheer.com to help you find equ amazing
employees that are 80% less than the US
equivalent he go blah blah and then he
sent me the screenshot we can show this
on the screen so this newsletter went to
12,000 people it had an 11% click rate
which is the power of a story versus an
ad and so normally an ad would get like
a one to 3% click exactly so this is 10
times better why is it 10 times better
because again he kind of opened up the
kimono and told the story so to support
sheep.com it says 1300 people clicked
that link and then that's where he got
you know you can even assume even like a
3% conversion on 1300 people is going to
get you you know your whatever your I
don't know the math but like let's say
your first 20 30 customers to get the
ball rolling and for a business like
this where each customer's worth
thousands of dollars that was enough to
to sort of really actually move the
needle and then what he did was he just
kept doing the same thing and so if you
want to hire people go use Shephard
that's really the the shill but I
actually like this method a lot I
remember that Ryan Hoover did this
amazingly with product hunt also I
remember him doing this so he did the
hand toand combat where every morning he
would go to Phil's Coffee in San
Francisco at like 5 or 6 in the morning
and for the first three hours of the day
all he would do would be reply to
people's tweets so anytime somebody said
about something about product hunt he
would reply personally anytime somebody
mentioned a cool product he would be
like that's awesome do you want to post
that on product hunt I gave you access
and he would he would manually Brute
Force do this in the morning but then he
would go and he would go to Fast Company
and say hey do you want to cover product
hunt and they're like I never heard of
it no so he's like damn I really want to
get pressed but I can't uh they're not
they don't want to talk about product
and it's not sexy enough so then instead
what he did was he would go to a Fast
Company he would say hey I signed up a
thousand customers for my side project
in a weekend can I tell you how we did
it and I wrote this blog post it's
already written in this Google doc will
you guys run this and as a guest post
and then if you go look producton has a
bunch of posts that he wrote and so it
was like he would get to 100 customers
then he would write the post of how he
got to 100 customers get that posted
somewhere on Indie hackers or whatever
that would get him to a thousand then he
would go write the post of how I got to
a thousand because he's like the
generically interesting story people
aren't that interested in product hunt
but they are interested in how a guy can
bootstrap his side hustle to a thousand
customers in a week and he did the work
for them and he did the work for them
and so again it was a no-brainer offer
to basically say hey it's written do you
want to run this or should I go you know
I like fasting update you guys should
run this if not I I guess I'll go ask
somebody else and that that method I saw
was something somebody else did that
worked really well all right solid
thrill the shill good job you forgot the
call to action join shepard.com support
shepard.com support shepard.com um all
right what's your uh what's your next
one okay so my next one I call pissing
in the pond and pissing in the pond is
as good of a method as it sounds like so
what you want to do like you said sounds
like a horrible method there's riches
and niches similarly what you want to do
is not try to boil the ocean bad phrase
you want to piss in the pond okay so
boiling the is when you go try to get
the mass Market to care about what
you're doing doesn't really work what
you want to do is say all right I'm
small anyways to me when I have no
customers 10 customers is a big win 100
customers is a a phenomenal win and so
where can I go that is small but hyper
obsessed and so what we did when we
launched our e-commerce brand was we
know we knew that there were Facebook
groups dedicated to literally like
comparing products in our niche these
weren't big right they're maybe 5,000
people total and this is like in
Facebook you know it's like that's a
that's kind of a small overall Facebook
group and what we would do is we go
there and we would do the Marshall thing
just like he did with Shephard we would
go tell our story which was why we
started this brand so instead of saying
buy our product we would say um hey
y'all wanted to share my story the ups
and downs that's gone over the last six
months trying to launch a brand that
does this and then we would share like
here were some of the UPS we had here
were some of the downs we had when we
got screwed or we got scammed or we were
so naive and people really started
rooting for us and you can get people to
root for you um and so that's how we for
my Ecom Biz we did I think uh 30,000 in
month one in in Revenue about I think
28,000 specifically and our ad spend was
only maybe 500 or thousand so we did to
try ads but most of the the revenue that
first month came from this group and
this was really good
because who those 100 customers are
actually matters and if you can get a
100 UND of the hyper obsessed people of
a niche to actually give a [__] about
you and know about you they are the ones
who spread the word they're the ones
that other people look to for
recommendations and so it's actually
quite valuable to go get to go piss in
that pond and so you go to that group
and the way you do it that's acceptable
where you're making the water warmer not
uncomfortable is you tell a story of the
ups and the Downs you've had trying to
build something cool in this space why
you started what worked for you what
didn't work for you some of the big
mistakes you made and people will then
root for for you because you're the
underdog now let me take you another
example of this so I can't believe we
even did this business I'm embarrassed
to even say this is a business I was
doing but in our idea lab we had a
hackathon and in the hackathon our our
devops guy was like Hey I built this app
it's like a four four square was hot at
the time this is way back in the day
he's like four it's four square for
beers and he's like basically every time
you drink a beer watch this you scan the
label and it checks in that beer and it
keeps track of all the different beers
you've drank and then everybody's like
starts laughing we're like that's
awesome man that's cool you know beer
who who doesn't love beer and so we were
kind of like maybe there's a thing here
and actually to this day actually there
is a business called untap that does us
and there's a there's a version of this
for wine we were just the wrong people
to start this business similar to the
sushi business I made the same mistake
again which was you don't even drink
beer do you the guy who I drink beer but
I'm not like a craft beer off ficado guy
who loves to go try new craft beers oh
like drinking it you're like ah yes a
Miller like this is
beautiful brewery tour once and the guy
was like smell these Hops and I was like
no thanks I don't you guys have french
fries exactly I was like can I just
drink it I don't care about all this so
anyways um we had this app called beer
hunt Okay so how do you do it there was
a craft beer so it was like where do you
get again if you go to the the mass
Market Mass Market is like me they don't
care about beer enough to care about
this product but instead there was a
craft beer tasting festival or something
like that in San fr Isco we went there
and we tried to make a splash this is
also the uh what I'll call the booth
babes method is how do you actually make
a splash at an event and so we weren't
hosting this one we were attending and
so we dressed up like it was October
Fest we dressed up like in our like
whatever leader hen and whatever we wore
outfits like we were straight from
Germany and we came and we created we
were like people probably won't just
download our app if we say download our
app so how do we were you when you did
this 23 24 uh um and so we but you know
our whole company was was older but
we're all there and they were there were
down for it which I liked uh you know
like our Engineers are doing this and so
that um what we did was we created a
scavenger hunt for the conference we
were like hey here's a little card um if
you can mark off all these things at
this conference uh we're going to give
one person like you know the like
whatever some beard dream it was like
you know you're going to get a year
supply of of craft beer and it was like
it didn't even matter what the prize the
idea was like people are going to wander
around this place anyways they were
happy to play the game of like marking
things off as they went so we had our
branded little scavenger hunt they would
do it and at the end we would had a guy
standing at the door he would collect
them he would give them out and he would
collect them and on it they had their
email address and so now we had
basically I think we had 1400 leads or
something from the St 1400 leads of
people who are so into craft beer that
they will go to this like craft beer
like pay money to go to this craft beer
tasting festival type thing and so then
that those became the first you know
whatever 700 customers or 700 people to
download our app and they really gave a
[__] so that that really cranked the
engine to get something started seeing
you at a 23y old you at a like fancy
Brewery it reminded me of a time one
time I told Neville I go Neville I've
never been to a strip club or somehow it
came up and he was like I'm gonna take
you right now and I was like I I don't
really want to go to a strip club he's
like well you have your flight at 5:00
p.m. there's a shrip club near the
airport in Texas it's 2:00 let's go and
I don't drink so like it's even worse
and we go out to this strip club and I'm
so uncomfortable I'm rubbing my hands I
don't know what to do with my hands and
uh I'm like and like these strippers
come up and like touch my shoulders and
they're like hey can I get you anything
and I was like yeah can I get some
ketchup for these
fries like the waitresses
yeah like and the food was only $6 it
was $1 for fries $5 for sandwich I
remember texting my wife and I'm like do
I how much do I tip because I kind of
took up a seat but I didn't do
anything it's just like it was the most
uncomfortable that I've ever been it's
like the first and only time I've ever
been to a strip club was two o'clock at
the airport in Austin strip club uh just
can can I tell you the one time I went
to strip club it's it's a incredible
story so I've been one time in my life
you know maybe 22 years old something
like that and we go and it's me people
know me so I don't need to describe me
but it's my buddy who's like the ladies
man this guy like was the Big Man on
Campus he you know like your dorm has
like an RA he like hooked up with the
Ra's girlfriend and it's like that gu a
Senor refresh like wow this guy just
amazing and so we go with this guy he's
the man and then we go with our other
buddy um who was like Mr longterm
relationship so he's been in a
relationship forever and never met never
never known this guy not in a
relationship but he had just broken up
and so we go to a strip club because you
know like in Vegas they're like hey boys
you want some free drinks get in this
limo we're like oh wow what's the cat
they drive you like 30 minutes away to a
strip club and there now you're here and
you have two free drink coupons that you
can go at the bar so me and the ladies
man we don't know what to do none of us
have ever been to strip club so we go to
the bar again what do I I'm
uncomfortable let me just like find a
safety net it's like let's go get a
drink yeah yeah yeah drink drink drink
that's a good idea and we go and then we
turn to look for our friend Mr long Mr
always wied up and he's not only not
with us he is holding hands with the
stripper going into the back room and
I'm like it's been less than like two
minutes we're like we're like uh we're
like what's he doing it's so we had
several questions
one um I can't like why is he doing this
so fast number two why is he going to
the back room isn't that like for like
the the high tier stuff like why isn't
he just sitting here and watching the
the Sher and three most importantly was
why' he pick her because he had
picked just objectively completely
scientifically the least attractive
stripper in the place and so 15 minutes
go by he comes back out and we're I'm
like I have a thousand questions what
happens in the back room how much does
it cost do you have to tip on top of the
cost I have so many logistical questions
but most importantly why'd you pick her
man you could have picked anyone here
and he goes oh you could pick
what he goes he goes oh he goes he goes
I thought it's like Harry Potter the one
chooses the
wizard to this day the line the one
chooses the wizard is like etched in my
soul it just applies to any
situation and neither of us have been to
a strip club since since never been
again same can't top that
um um all right I'll do one last one uh
Trends trends.co we're going to go from
shipper to
what the Sass yeah sassy to sass
yeah um I hope people have made it this
far um uh Trends Trends EO was a uh paid
research newsletter that I launched when
we sold it 18 months after launching it
I think it was doing four or 500,000 a
month in sales I think we had 20,000
users or so um and it was great whatever
I screwed up a bunch of stuff with that
but we got some results and the way that
we got results is we started and I I did
this like I as a little skunk project
and if you actually see the link I list
to my original gumroad project I made a
gumroad page and I think it was like 400
words of me just writing like a story
explaining so basically the story was
like in
1996 Jeff bezo saw this amazing stat
which was that the internet was growing
at 2,300 per. nothing grows that fast
bezo said unless it's in a Petri disc
and immediately then he knew that he had
to start an Internet company that sold
something um and so that was how it
started and then I said hey everyone I'm
Sam um I invest in a lot of companies or
I and or I have this company called the
hustle and I'm able to see a lot of
interesting things next quarter I'm
launching this product called Trends
where I'm going to um break down
interesting companies and explain how
they works and hopefully identify a
handful of Trends as shocking as this
Bezos one that he found so you're going
to be able to catch the wave instead of
Miss it I'm going to charge $300 a year
for this but right now you just spend
100 bucks and you get a lifetime of of
access and so I got originally I got um
a thousand or 2,000 people to sign up
for this and I'll explain how but before
we even launched this whole project I
ran Facebook ads against a this gumroad
page and it made $60,000 in pre-sales
and the way that I got the initial 100
users is the hustle at the time probably
had a million emails and I just found
the 300 engaged users and I sent them an
email that basically explained this
story and linked to the gumroad page um
and then what I did was I actually got
on the phone with all 100 of them and I
asked them why' you do this what are you
looking for what what are your
expectations and then I went and made
the first report based off of like some
of their insights and what they wanted
and then what we did was people would
sign up to the hustle and afterwards
they would see a page that says thank
you by the way we have something coming
soon and would link to this gumroad page
now that's a little bit if you're
listening to this and you don't have an
audience you're like w what the [__]
that's not really actionable but I had
to share this is how we built like I
think it was 400 or 500,000 by month 18
and so it worked and we built the
product around just calling those people
yeah that's like a you had a Launchpad
you had an audience that you had built
for years and then you were able to do
this and I wouldn't recommend doing that
just to launch a product but if you
don't really know what product you want
to launch it's not a bad idea idea to uh
to build a Launchpad along the way so
just to recap I did the same thing with
Hampton and I would DM people on Twitter
and you could say I have an audience so
it helps I didn't use my audience but I
did use my reputation so some people had
known me um so I I but I called emailed
people on LinkedIn and I called people
on Twitter so if you want to do this
methodology you could still do it that
way yeah and we didn't mention a couple
of the obvious ones so and we kind of
loosely mentioned it cold outre there's
a bunch of traditional methods to to try
to do this we
told you what we did which was partly
because we were young and dumb and we
didn't know any better we didn't know
that you could just I didn't know you
could just run ads or just do cold
emails I would go door to door instead
um but also you know it some of it's in
the specific so for example from milk
Road I had an audience so I had a
newsletter I had this podcast and I
could have just mentioned it but I
layered on another tactic which is what
I call the David Blaine method and you
know David Blaine will do this [__]
where he's like I'm going to freeze
myself for a week yeah watch me you know
slightly torture myself and try to do
something incredible and it's like all
right he's like I'm gonna freeze myself
in a block of ice I'm gonna bury myself
underground I'm GNA hold my breath until
I pass out yeah I'm gonna he literally
did one where he's like I'm gonna hold
on to these balloons and fly away it's
like okay dope and he did it he like
flew away like the movie up and so he um
David bla does this stuff so when we
started the milk road I was like okay if
I think if I told people that hey I'm
starting a daily newsletter about crypto
for people that want to read um you know
the latest kind of news and info on
crypto I think people would sign up but
I wanted to like juice it a little bit
so how did I go a little bit further I
was like let me do a stunt and so I said
I am funding and of course you know you
have to have some money to do this this
version of it but you could really David
blae puts his body Through Torture I put
some money on the line so what I did was
I said I'm gonna put a million dollars
in this wallet you can go look at the
address right now here's a million
dollars in a wallet and then I'm going
to try to turn this into 10 million
through trading crypto and this is like
um you know Dave from bar stool does
this with his Dave day trader uh you
know Jason calanis tried to copy that
and do J Trader like people try to do a
version of this where it's like watch me
try to run this bankroll up uh I I
learned this from back in the poker days
I used to love when anyone would do this
in the gambling or poker space and
they'd be like I'm starting with this
bankroll I'm either going broke I'm
going to this level I'm get I'm getting
to this Milestone and here I'm GNA post
all of my history and it never works out
but it's really fun to watch and that's
what I figured and that's exactly what
happened I managed to turn a million
dollars because we bought it like you
know P crypto into what became like
$350,000 at the bottom and then now it's
a little bit higher but um basically
it's like watch me lose money but either
way watch me lose money is also
entertaining people will subscribe to
watch me get my ass kicked to watch
they'll subscribe to watch me kick ass
and even better they'll subscribe to
find out whether I get my ass kicked or
whether I kick ass and the other version
of this is people call it now build in
public people do that before that buffer
and convert kit did this stuff where
they would share like all their team
salaries they would share all their
team's Revenue uh or the company's
revenue and it it tends to work I
remember this guy named Pat Flynn from
Smart passive income he was one of the
first guys to do this he would share his
monthly revenue and where it all came
from and I would go there every month to
see like what he was doing and it
totally worked the the extreme access
works but I think the other one is
calling your shot or uh basically
creating a a storyline so it's basically
like what is a story there's the hero
they have a goal and they have an
obstacle
and then there's some Stakes there's
there's something on the line and I
think that's the way to like juice that
up so it's not just I'm going to build
in public so I'll I'll provide a monthly
update it's I'm gonna try to do X and if
I don't do X you know like there's a
there's a like I'm putting something on
the line trying to get there and I'm G
to try to do this incredible thing not
just inch my way forward you know if I
said Hey I'm um you know I'll show you
you know my you know some of the things
I'm investing in that'd be okay but to
say I'm going to try to turn a million
dollars into 10 million or go bust
that people want to watch more and so
you know I think the David blae
spectacle method is another one I want
to see you do that with your second trip
to the strip
club build in public
bro I'm gonna order as much food and
free water as I can until they kick me
out of the strip club can I make it over
or under 6 hours before they realize
this guy's just here for the
fries all right we got to end there
that's the pod
[Music]